FIGHT IN THE STREETS WITH BROOM
STICKS IF THEY HAVE TO.
THE RUSSIANS WILL NEVER, EVER
OCCUPY THAT COUNTRY.
>> HOW DO YOU SEE, THOUGH, THIS
ILLEGAL INVASION BY RUSSIA?
>> WE'VE GOT HISTORY TO LOOK
BACK ON.
THERE'S BEEN A FEW WARS OVER
HISTORY, PROBABLY THOUSANDS OF
THEM.
THEY END WHEN ONE OR BOTH
PARTIES FIGHT TO THE POINT OF
EXHAUSTION.
THEN THEY SIT DOWN AND TALK AND
GET A RESOLUTION.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT HAPPENS
HERE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, THOUGH, THAT
NEITHER SIDE IS EVEN CLOSE TO
THAT POINT.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE NOT GIVING
UP.
PUTIN HAS NOT WEAKENED THEIR
RESOLVE.
HE HAS VERY MUCH STEELED THEIR
THERE'S A LONG WAYS TO GO.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE RUSSIA
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS AS TO HOW FAR THEY
WANT TO GO.
THEY'VE HAD 100,000 CASUALTIES.
ANOTHER GREAT LOSS FOR PUTIN WAS
THE GREAT MYTH THAT WAS OUT
THERE AROUND THE WORLD, WAS THE
MIGHT OF THE RUSSIAN MILITARY.
I MEAN, IT'S BEEN STRIPPED BARE.
THEIR PROWESS ON THE BATTLEFIELD
HAS JUST BEEN STRIPPED NAKED.
IT'S NOT THERE.
HERE THEY ARE, QUOTE, A SUPER
POWER, I GUESS ONLY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NUCLEAR WEAPONS, FIGHTING A
COUNTRY, 125 MILLION PEOPLE
FIGHTING WITH STICKS AND STONES.
THE RUSSIANS ARE LOSING.
YOU GOT TO REMEMBER THESE THINGS
WAX AND WANE.
PUTIN WILL RESPOND.
I'LL YOU WHAT.
HIS CONSCIENCE IS AN AMAZING
THING.
I SAID ALL ALONG THAT AT SOME
POINT IN TIME IN THE NOT TOO
DISTANT FUTURE HE'S GOING TO BE
PLAYING CHECKERS WITH ADOLPH
HITLER IN A VERY DIFFERENT
PLACE.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT A
HUMAN BEING COULD TREAT OTHER
HUMAN BEINGS LIKE THIS.
HE'S STOLEN THESE YOUNG MEN IN
HIS COUNTRY INTO THE MEAT
GRINDER EVERY DAY AND THEY'RE
KILLING WOMEN AND CHILDREN IN
UKRAINE.
LIKE YOU SAY, WHAT MAKES HIM
THINK THE WAY HE DOES?
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
HAVE AN AUTOCRAT AND ONE THAT'S
BEEN IN A POWER FOR A LONG, LONG
TIME AND HAS ABSOLUTE POWER.
HE CAN DO THIS.
>> DO YOU HAVE THAT CONCERN
STILL THAT PUTIN COULD JUST SAY,
YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M LOSING SO BAD
THAT I'M JUST GONNA --
>> YOU SAID STILL.
I NEVER HAD IT IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND I DON'T HAVE IT NOW.
HE KNOWS WHAT THE SITUATION IS
THERE.
YOU KNOW, THE USE OF A NUCLEAR
WEAPON WOULD CHANGE DRAMATICALLY
THE WORLD IN VERY SHORT ORDER.
THERE'S TWO THINGS I'M CONVINCED
HE'S NOT GOING TO DO.
ONE IS USE A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THE OTHER IS TO ATTACK